we've got to talk about iPads and what
the heck apple is going to do with them
because they just announced the brand
new apple pencil 3 and wait a second oh
it's the apple pencil 2 that's what I
meant to say wait wait dang it we've
already had this one for 5 years um oh
okay it's the apple pencil USBC there
you go I got it anyway let's talk about
iPads or the new 11th gen model which we
didn't get even though we just got the
new Apple pencil which means that we're
unlikely to see it get released this
year because they would have released
them at the same time now I know what
you're going to say we just got a brand
new major iPad redesign with this iPad
10 so there's really no point in
releasing another update but that's
actually not true in 2020 Apple updated
the basic iPad with only one noticeable
change change an upgrade from the A10
ship to the a12 and that was enough for
them to Warrant a new iPad update on top
of that for the past 6 years they've
updated this basic iPad every single
year without skipping a beat so why
would they not do that this year and
simply give us a USBC apple pencil well
I think I know why but before I explain
it I want to go through what the heck
happened with all of these iPad leaks as
well as if we're actually going to be
seeing a new iPad Mini 7 and iPad air6
this year or not over the past week
we've had quite a few Publications
talking about brand new iPads coming out
this week including the new iPad 11 and
they unfortunately were all wrong so in
that case who was right well we do have
a m quo from the very beginning back in
September saying that there are no new
iPads likely launching this year now
when I first heard that it was extremely
hard to believe I thought he was
completely wrong because this seems so
unapp to have a year where you have no
iPads at all and it's weird because this
would be the first time ever in the
history of the iPad with no iPad updates
within that year so basically my
thoughts on that were that m is wrong
and I still to this day don't know if I
actually believe him because it just
doesn't make sense for Apple to do this
now it did make a little bit more sense
was a leaker from waybo back in
September saying that only the iPad Air
should be getting updated this year and
I completely agree because we should be
getting this air for a couple of
different reasons but before I get into
that I've got to show you this the
modern replacement for my old bulky
wallet the ridge wallet it's the th
wallet I could find that can hold all of
my cards up to 12 plus cash with over 30
plus durable colors and styles all with
RFID blocking materials and a lifetime
guarantee you can even get 30% off your
order if you buy a matching key case
which holds up to six keys to keep them
from jingling just go to ridge.com maxc
and use my code maxtech for 10% off your
order thanks rid for sponsoring the
channel now back to the video first of
all Apple released the last couple of
iPad Airs on a
1.5e timeline opposite from the iPad Pro
and since we're expecting to get that as
soon as the spring of next year that
would mean that this fall is the perfect
time because it's basically 1 and 1/2
years since the previous iPad Air and
then now for reason number 2 we're all
expecting the iPad Air to get a very
simple update with the M2 chip which
importantly must come before the launch
and reveal of the M3 chip which we were
expecting this fall for many months but
now it looks like that's getting delayed
as well apparently muko also said that
there's going to be no MacBooks for the
rest of this year and I completely
didn't believe him because it doesn't
make sense but now that we're getting
into October and just the leaks aren't
there it's St to look like the case so
if the iPad Air isn't coming this year
with the M2 Chip then when the heck is
the M3 chip going to get revealed the
summer of next year that's just crazy
because that would be the biggest gap
between M chip releases since the
original M1 so far it's been exactly a
year and a half because we had the M1 in
November of 2021 a year and a half later
we had the M2 in the summer of 2022 and
now the fall is perfectly a year and a
half and no it looks like it's actually
getting delayed but with that said I'm
still holding on to hope for an M2 iPad
Air maybe next month and that's of
course because we didn't get an iPad
this week and instead we got a new Apple
pencil USBC which Steve Moser leaked on
X within iPad OS 17.1 beta software as
well as Mac otakara who correct ly
predicted the pencil is coming instead
of an iPad and of course we also have
Mark German's leak who himself said we
are unlikely to get any new iPads this
month at all and it looks like the goat
is right again so with that said are we
still going to be seeing some new iPads
this year or is Apple literally going to
do exactly what M quo said and give us
no new iPad updates for the first time
in the iPad's history well once again in
terms of the iPad Air 6 I really think
that this one should be coming I don't
think they can delay it because of the
M3 chip reveal there's just going to be
too much things going on early next year
with that so I really hope it's coming
hopefully later next month but as far as
the iPad Mini 7 Apple has actually had
huge gaps between different iPad Mini
models in the past and they could
totally do this again because the iPad
Mini 6 is honestly amazing it's so good
I actually bought it for my family and
my kids really enjoy it but then again
they could wait until the air gets
released if it's getting delayed and
kind of release both of them at the same
time because there is a chance that
Apple delays everything this time around
more than we expected they could delay
the M3 reveal even longer they could
delay the M3 iPad Pro until the fall who
knows maybe even delay the high-end M3
Pro and M3 Max MacBook Pros until like
like I don't know 2025 no I mean that
sounds too crazy but who knows Apple's
delaying everything so the big question
is why would Apple delay everything so
much in such an odd way well my biggest
reason that I can think of is actually
an economic downturn that we're getting
into right now smartphone sales have
been dropping all over the place
especially for Android phones and even
the new iPhone 15 lineup
those sales have been going down in
China compared to last year which is
really weird because this is a pretty
nice iPhone 15 upgrade on top of that
Mac sales are dropping they're down 23%
globally compared to last year doing
even worse than all of the other
mainstream PC brands with Brands like HP
that are actually growing why well
because they sell really cheap laptops
and PCs so it seems like there's
currently a tech recession particularly
for the highest end premium Tech Brands
and people right now are trending
towards holding on to their current
devices right now and waiting to upgrade
so if Apple goes ahead and releases new
products as usual there is definitely
going to be less upgrade demand for them
so what's the point they could just keep
selling the current ones and they could
save all of these new updates until the
economy starts to hold hopefully recover
sometime next year that's when people
are going to start buying again and
that's actually why I think Apple gave
us such a lackluster Mac Pro update
without any of the new Big rumored
features that we were looking into
especially swapping out the GPU cards
custom gpus all of that nothing happened
at all they gave us a very very simple
M2 Ultra Mac Pro update so right now
it's very clear that businesses and
startups are in cost cutting mode since
interest rates have skyrocketed and it's
a lot more difficult and expensive to
get new capital and cash for investment
so if Apple releases a top-notch new
very expensive Mac Pro less businesses
will be buying since they're actually
choosing right now to instead lay people
off and save cash so anyway what we're
seeing this year with the lack of iPad
updates and other new updates could be
related to the economy more than
anything else but I'm still here hoping
on at least a new iPad a 6 with the M2
Chip coming sometime later this year but
that would of course mean that MinGa quo
would be wrong and he's been pretty dang
good with his timeline and leaks so
there you guys go those are my thoughts
on the 2023 iPad leaks and what's going
to be happening of course this new apple
pencil USBC craziest name such a weird
situation especially since it doesn't
have pressure sensitivity and doesn't
support wireless magnetic charging such
a weird product but I guess it makes
sense for the $79 price tag hopefully
you enjoy this video and if you did you
can subscribe above and definitely check
out that video right there talking about
this new apple pencil USBC and
everything you need to know about it
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
y